very smart it's it almost matches a
little bit are you feeling sparkly right
now is this just one of the magical
moments of life this is a high what was
it like when they call your name what
goes through your mind I don't know sort
of can't remember any of it now yeah
yeah royalty is so good to you now you
go from Queen Anne to now Queen
Elizabeth yeah okay so what does that
transition been like and the
expectations of the Queen are so big
how's that been well yes Blaine Queen
Anne's much easier because no one
remembers what she was like sort of do
anything but Queen Elizabeth everybody
knows you know yes and yes the voice so
boy so I've got to do an impression of
Claire and the Queen yeah how is that
how is it taking over for somebody who
was impersonating the woman um well I
literally the first two weeks did do an
impression of Claire and then now don't
know what I'm doing now but but it must
be amazing and how much fun was it
working with those ladies on the
favorite and the the kind of push and
pull in the tug that they had going on
was phenomenal oh we had such a ball we
genuinely took on so well and we I think
we will be friends for life really yes
you also pulled off the madness of Queen
Anne like oh whatever be how did you dig
so deep and find that in have you
shaking yourself a van yet oh yes no I
don't really carry them with me no no I
give it all on the day and then you can
walk away from it okay your favorite
part of playing Queen in ooh I loved
being able to eat and load
Wow eating was your favorite part of it
because she was you know and it needs to
put on weight to play her so that was
actually really enjoyable how do you
celebrate and where do you take this
Golden Globe I'm going to try and go to
every party on offer are you yeah
will you go with your girls will you go
with Hannah and Rachel are they out
there waiting for you oh and by the way
is this thing heavier than anything the
Queen ever did know it really is massive
but doggone it it's beautiful is it no
one right no one's enjoying this moment
more than you've been at all right
congratulations you made it a phenomenal
movie in your portrayal of an is great
cannot wait to see your Elizabeth cannot
wait to see your Elizabeth hey by the
way where will it pick up where will the
story pick up we do until the end of 70s
maybe early eighties Wow so 60s old 7
into the 70s lot went on with that
family a lot went on with their family
alright we cannot wait to see some
costumes maybe you'll get another one of
those did you get a sandwich who was
handing out to say where did she store
the sandwiches bag but she on the
previous year she said she got so hungry
she said never again so she brought a
big bag of sandwiches and hands around
how were the sandwiches really good were
they what kind ham and Brie French bread
ham and Brie on French bread really and
she just had him in a bag and no one
stopped her they took one the table when
we got there asked me where they came
from I was like listen from Melissa you
want to thank her tell her thank you
Melissa McCarthy thank you so much you
stopped me from being too drunk ok
sandwich awesome thank you
congratulations
[Music]